what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have a
special guest on the channel ali who i
met through his podcast what's up guys
uh ollie here thanks pearly for um for
having me yeah i've got a podcast called
shambles fm comedy podcast talking about
dating relationships
everything through like a comedic lens
but yeah yeah it's actually pretty funny
i was on like a week ago yeah yeah when
are you posting it
maybe i think
not next week actually next week yeah
okay so today as you guys know jess is
out of town sad so i'm having some
people fill in for her so
today we are reacting to fresh and fit
um
debating that australian lady so
i i haven't seen this clip yet and a lot
of you asked me to react to it so we're
gonna
we're gonna give our thoughts have you
seen fresh and fit before oh yeah yeah
i've seen i've seen the pod but i
haven't actually seen this clip um i
wouldn't say i'm a it's a weird one
i wouldn't say i'm a fan you wouldn't
say you're a fan no
just because i don't think they practice
what they preach
okay yeah why not because that was that
whole thing with the sugar baby yeah
that that was a little shady it was so
it was so shady it was a little shady
yeah just yeah
okay well we're gonna we're gonna react
today and see see what we think
uh you go to beta studio than we do
jackie and i we had we had quite the
weekend in florida with missy elliot no
jesus it was one of those that was some
time ago oh well stories you can't
really tell on broadcast media that you
know you gotta you gotta be face to face
couple of joints you know just chatting
you know that i miss you when i see you
in front of missy elliott like you guys
actually let her into your country so
i'll hear that bro no no no we went
there we were in miami
who's missy elliot oh the the rapper oh
wait wait was that a serious question
you've definitely heard a song before
which song uh
well okay now all my skills have just
escaped my head um
oh god you don't seem okay
you definitely
[Laughter]
uh
uh get your free console
get your free gun good job no get your
freak out
get free get your get your freak on you
you haven't
is this like this is like a song to get
freaky to
i mean
maybe but okay no oh
you've definitely heard it you
definitely i'll play it later
okay
no i said
guys let's go back to what you said
because i want to
take this a little more
do you believe that any woman in a
relationship should not have instagram
or are you saying that just women who
are in a relationship and are
posing in their bikinis or you know
doing any kind of sultry sort of stuff
they're the ones that shouldn't have
instagram what do you think before he
answers
having instagram in a relationship yeah
i think i think i get i get what they're
saying because
it gives
it gives an outlet to cheat and it's
easier for
women to cheat through social media than
it is for a guy okay i think
so is that like she's for the streets
it depends what she's posting if she's
like posting her ass on
yeah what about you follow me on
instagram yeah yeah is my instagram for
the streets no no i wouldn't say okay so
that instagram would be a green light
yeah okay okay
well if you're in a serious committed
relationship with a guy and you have you
know sexy photos of yourself on the
internet you know instagram is just one
medium that you can do it yeah it is
cheating
cheating like what about the guy is he
if he if he's in a relationship is he
allowed to have instagram yeah we're
different we're not in our undies
i don't think i was asking you i was
asking these guys
let me ask let me ask you a question are
men and women equal
yeah of course yeah no we're not at all
we're not okay uh men and women are
different
do you think men and women are equal
independent
[Laughter]
it depends what you mean by equal
i think i think it's not about being
equal because we're never really going
to reach true equality anywhere i think
it's more about
i think we need to spend more time
concentrating championing our
differences
whether instead of making everyone
trying to be the exactly the same
because yeah not gonna yeah no i agree
actually i don't because i feel like in
any relationship there's always it's
never equal yeah like even in
friendships there's one leader one
follower exactly like it's not
nothing's equal
um but
i kind of feel the same way about guys
with
shirtless selfies
fair like if a guy has a bunch of
shirtless selfies i kind of look at you
i kind of look at you funny it's
unnecessary especially like
unless you're like a fitness influencer
or something i don't see any reason why
you're
all
yeah i just don't see any reason why
your shirt should be off yeah but i do
think it's different though because
a girl's ass like dudes are gonna like
be like oh my god but like a guy's
shirtless selfie like i just it's not
the same effect i don't know i'd be like
oh that's nice but not
yeah maybe i think there's like a small
percentage of guys that will literally
have girls thirsting over them but
that's like like one percent of like
so yeah
most of me it's like a dad
like put that away
put that away
yes we're different of course we're
different but you know were you talking
about pay parity what are you talking
about when it comes to being different
well the definition of equality is being
the same in quantity size degree or
value and nothing between us is equal
we're very different what i mean by
don't think we are of equal value
uh well here's the thing from a human's
rights perspective and you know the
value of your life yes we're equal no
one is better than anyone in that regard
but when it comes to biology and
intersexual dynamics we're 100 percent
difference and the reason why that is
true scientifically that he's he's
correct we are different right but
what i don't understand is how does that
apply to the question that i asked when
yes
okay so the reason why is because we
have differing sexual strategies men
want quantity women want quality so
our sexual strategies are literally
opposing each other so men want to be
able to get with as many girls as
possible right unlimited sexuality shout
outs our guide roll tomorrow we talk
about this in detail versus women i say
women want typically unlimited security
from the best man that they can get
versus men want to get the most women
they can get
so it
you think that's true
to an extent yeah to an extent i think i
think
at a certain point that stops
just because it's long dealing with
multiple girls all the time it's just
it's long it's effort too much work yes
it's like a part-time job it's just
it's a part-time job explain it's in
great detail
just to have like it's just like
spinning multiple plates and having to
talk to a lot of people and then and
it's expensive
okay
that's the main it's an actual
investment so
he's not wrong but at the same time
there comes a point where
you just can't be bothered anymore no i
um i agree for the girls because it's
not like like girls have so many
requirements
to like be with them you know what i
mean yeah like even even me like i could
think of five things off the top of my
head a guy has to have a
girl
five things uh five
close to my height or taller okay um
he has to he can't
be super loved
okay
the guys that are like male feminists
i'm like
you're talking to the wrong [ __ ] you're
talking to the wrong
not me
that's like nothing makes me want to end
a date sooner i don't i just don't
understand i just don't i don't think
you can be a male feminist
you kind of have the vibe who you me
just because of the glasses i always
assume
it's out of this video
reacting with the milk
how do you think you were invited
not just
i was hoping
just to clarify guys i'm not a feminist
i got the wrong person
but
or i can't do i can't do bombs either
okay
so like but dude doesn't it's okay if
you're starting a business or something
but man's just sitting around all day
doing nothing
yeah so
or um
i don't know i can i can i'm not going
to go on but
but like you you get the idea there's
like a list of requirements where like
and then it just seems like it's more
like hot and there yeah
[Laughter]
pretty much really willing
i feel like we're yeah we're we're more
visual yeah yeah as guys that's that's
that's the first thing that
we look for straight away and then
everything else comes second if it does
come into it at all question yeah
for me there could be a guy that's like
super good looking very attractive to
you but if he opens his mouth
and says the wrong thing it's like gone
can girls do the same thing 100 however
you're still smash
but you're still
like you'd be like you'll just be like
maybe like like from behind
like you could like hear her talk less
she will cross my airpods in and just
have music playing
ah yeah yeah no um it can't happen the
other way but like i said
the difference is a guy will stick a guy
will feel that way
and then still smash right
yeah and
i think
that's why you see girls that like hate
men
and i've always like the girls that hate
men a lot they've always been ran
through because why else you hate men
you don't reach if you don't deal with a
lot of men
it's either it's either they've they've
been run through or they're bitter
because they don't get attention
oh it's
like
the whales yeah yeah
it's been that way the beginning of time
powerful and strong men have had hordes
of women and then women align themselves
with the strongest men
so we don't play by the same set of
rules and our sexual strategies
influences how we view the world how we
view the opposite gender how we uh try
to
uh procreate with each other we're very
different so what's what men can do
women can't necessarily do sometimes so
we're not the same
and it's just unfortunate
that that does not benefit women for
once
sorry so just going back to that
question that i ask can a man be on
instagram
in a relationship
yes but not a woman
it's it's not the same
why does it depend on the content that
they're putting out if i'm shirtless on
instagram like
showing me big fat man boobs and
gyrating around sir put those away
[Music]
i'm sorry to help you
sexy dance
that would be cheap what if i was just
on there talking about you know fitness
apps and stuff that's a whole different
vibe so it's content related right
yeah but the thing is is that i don't
think people understand this that a man
that's that one
even a man that's extremely good looking
is not gonna get nearly the amount of
options that a woman that's
me mediocre that is so not true
do you know how many hot guys get dm'd
on instagram oh we're not talking about
dms we're talking about real life
benefits like no you're going to be
served first at the shop and stuff like
that i'm talking about instagram you're
saying a man can go on instagram in a
relationship and it not because
so okay um i'm gonna get one of my guys
to show you guys something but yes a lot
of women are unaware of this but men
unless they're in the top
two percent of looks and aesthetics and
everything else like that they get
virtually no play in online dating sites
instagram men don't get as much sexual
attention as women think yeah that's so
true and i was actually i was at work
drinks um a few days ago and we're just
talking about dating apps and literally
one of the guys was like guys i've been
on dating apps for two years and i've
never got a like
yet like it's it's
and to me i was i was shocked i was like
wait what but it's what you're saying is
real there's a whole
the majority of guys
don't get attention like that
do you have girls dm you from your show
nicholas
no no um
a few a few sometimes
yeah sometimes like how many how every
day
oh no no no every every week
like once a week
twice a week about once a week maybe
once a week so you'll get like four dms
from girls a month
yeah but yeah yeah pretty much out of
the four how many how many would you
like
what's the quality decent oh yeah yeah
quality if the quality
there are some times where i get i feel
insulted when someone that isn't off
quality slides in and i'm like
is this my level
i mean
let me show you this is like oh my god
it like doesn't end
oh snap
this is like that's not even the hidden
like it doesn't
but to be fair most of these people like
let me show you
like what am i gonna do with that
oh oh come on oh no but that's like 90
percent of them dude
he looks about 5'4
no that's what i mean like but you like
like
because i i know what he's saying and
girls will get a lot of dms but they're
always from weird guys that don't have
profile pictures
so it's like
like yeah you get a lot of attention but
it's not from the guys you you want half
the time no i hear that
yeah yeah like so
it's not like i'm tempted to like call
up jose sorry jose
give jose a chance jose deserves some
play
but you don't admit so i don't know i do
understand what he's saying though so
but i do think
i don't know i'm really unattracted to
guys that do this shirtless selfie thing
too yeah yeah yeah
no
what are you thinking
i'm not sure yeah i'm not sure i'm just
okay well we'll keep going issue is that
women see the world through their view
they think i get a lot of attention so
attractive guys must be getting a lot of
attention too and that couldn't be
further from the truth
men do not get nearly the same amount of
uh sexual attention they're still
getting
because a girl might get say let's say
50 dms that are have guys wanting to
date her when the guy gets 20 dms yes
there might be a little difference there
but they're still getting hit on by yeah
but okay but the difference is out of
the 50 there's maybe one or two you'd
consider and the guy would consider all
20.
guys don't
but what she's missing the point in the
fact that yeah we make the first move
yeah that's true that is true it's
harder for guys i'm not even gonna yeah
i'm not gonna argue like girls don't
really they don't always they don't
always slide into your dms like they'll
they might like a few pictures they
might
they'll they'll drop the handkerchief
yeah to give you the signal to move in
but
most of the time it's gonna be us so
what's she talking about
you can't compare you can't she's
irritating me now
this is this is true it's it's
definitely harder for guys to like yeah
i agree i agree
back to the old night club the rules
let's go back to the nightclub if you're
at the nightclub and the boys have
talked about this on the fresh and fit
podcast
boys will line up and we'll stand there
for all right let me show you something
real quick i'm gonna show you guys
something real quick oh wow
this is so interesting right here we
have uh a chart from okcupid and this
illustrates that even the most
attractive men in the light blue
are not even complete are barely
competing against girls in the mid-range
average girls not even half not even
half the last
not even half of the messages received i
forgot to make this full screen
now that's on a dating site on instagram
this is even more pronounced okay and
this doesn't account for you know okay
so you see the
hold on
you see this is the the females
and that's how attractive they are on
like this scale so it's saying that the
even average girls get more dms than the
hottest guys
but who are we getting the dms from
uh yeah the
like
with those guys
i
no it's still harder
it's still harder for guys it's just
wild
you're telling me the most attractive
guys
are still less than an average
huh
yeah because
like
even on off right yeah the most
successful girls aren't the hottest ones
they're the ones that like the the simps
think they can
attain ah
so like the girls that are like sixes
and sevens do better because the simps
like think they can get them in their
head that is why so then they'll get
more yeah so they make more money a lot
of the times
oh god man we need to do that man
what are you guys doing
well the plenty of fish data the tinder
data that we have
men do not get nearly as many options as
women and even if we're talking about
top tier guys they still cannot compete
men and women are not the same we're not
blank slate equals no i know they're not
the same come on let me finish please
it's not making you you're not actually
proving your point very well literally
have a chart on the screen proving that
women get far more attention than men
from the dating site that says women get
more attention yes that's obvious but
the point you made was that women should
not be allowed on instagram if they're
in a relationship because of the
attention they get and you're kind of
saying that guys can so question for you
if you're dating somebody right you
shouldn't be on dating i'm sorry i can't
take fresh serious
i just can't take and serious whatever
your thoughts
he's got a big chain though oh yeah
overcompensating
um
uh
no um
yeah this is this is wild but however
this this woman's back tracking a lot
she like she'll she'll go to make a
point and then myron will cancel out her
point and then she'll pretend that she
didn't make the point they always women
always do that and it's really like
watching this the goal post yeah
it's weird being because
i've experienced it being in the
situation but it's weird to be outside
and look and actually see it happening
from the outside yeah it's wild well and
like he just he he actually did a good
job disproving her point he had like a
chart ready to go he's doing well so far
he's prepared yeah i'll type myron
not on a dating app no okay perfect so
do you know right instagram is one of
the biggest data apps in the world
yeah i get that but it's also it's also
insane
people like to share other things it's
not all just thirst traps right so you
know every if if you're if you're in a
relationship not every girl is posting a
picture of herself in a bikini here's a
problem
[Laughter]
i don't
know
post a picture of himself let's say abs
shirtless right he gets his kitchen
agrippa's picture our story our post
right oh my god dude they have a dog
that's new
oh my god
okay that's so cute the problem is that
like attention is way out skills and
it's gonna be sexual because off rip
what do guys want they want to look at
pictures and take a shot at the girl
that's it girls man with myself always
cute he's handsome but no they're not
gonna really approach him like oh i want
you it's like okay cute heart eyes and
that's it girls are gonna go after it
like in a different way we're saying and
also we're specifying that when she has
sexy photos of herself on the internet
and she's in a relationship that is
cheating that is disrespectful to the
man it's not the
agree with that i think that you
shouldn't post those traps
100 i think that's disrespectful if if
if your girl's posting thirst traps
that's not your girl
that is that is she's everyone's girl
i've always said like why why
if i
being your partner should come with
certain benefits
why do i have to do all the work but
everyone gets the also gets to benefit
do you know what i mean like
i pay for spot five premium i'll be
pissed if if people on the free plan
were getting what i was getting
and he's in a relationship is that
cheating no no because it's not the same
at all
i know i know why it's different i know
why it's different guys listen as guys
we zoom in on the girls photos right
zoom in yeah this guy's talking about
himself
he's like
i know a lot about this
i know i can tell you what we do this is
his whole bag i was just doing it
yesterday
oh my gosh no he is he's
sometimes he he's dry snitching himself
right now
i wonder if his wife is watching
sweet let me let me break this down for
y'all okay so let's let's let's uh
uh jackie's let me let me ask you a
question what is your dream car
my dream car yes your dream car
oh she could have any cars
here okay
all right and just let me finish let me
finish this concept guys let me let me
get through it okay okay so let's say
you go to the uh to the dealership and
you buy a brand new range rover okay
range rover sport you've been wanting it
for a while fully decked out hundred
thousand dollars right australia 120 120
000 australian right 300 here we got the
luxury car tax you don't know 300k 300k
right so yeah you drive it off you you
know you shake hands at the car dealer
sign the paperwork
pay the money buy it cash you're good to
go drive it off the lot you don't care
about it losing value whatever this is
your dream car take it back to your
house
two weeks later okay
the uh the car dealer comes back to your
place says hey listen man
we're kind of showing our cars uh we're
gonna need to put it for sale sign on
your car and a couple days a week we're
gonna just need to put on display back
at the dealership and you know one or
two people might test drive it are you
okay with that how would that make you
feel
i know the analogy you're trying to make
i own that car i don't own my partner in
a relationship though i don't own them
again answer the question how would that
make you feel well obviously i wouldn't
be okay with that okay thank you that's
exactly how men feel when their women
post sexy photos of themselves on the
internet to advertise to other men
because women men are territorial with
their women it's been that way since the
beginning of time you don't own us in a
relationship so we can post okay but
it's that you of course you can do what
you want yes but he's just gonna leave
you after exactly like she's totally
missing the point it's not about
controlling it's about if you're doing
that you're just not going to find
someone that's going to stick around
yeah that's which that's literally is
that a guy with a backbone anyway yeah
there's a lot of guys that'll stick
around but not
and those weird guys that are like kind
of into it
that like
get off on like i don't know i don't
know anyway
well the other thing i i understand like
where she's coming from because i think
she what she's trying to say is like
there's certain guys that are so
controlling with like everything
and they just want to control everything
but i don't think it's controlling to
say don't post your ass on the internet
when you're dating you shouldn't even
have to say don't push awesome you
shouldn't be posting us
i always think about the internet's
gonna be around forever right yeah and
i'm gonna i'm gonna have like kids
hopefully you know
and and like grandkids and they're just
gonna go on the internet one day and be
like oh that's oh grandma oh yeah yeah
my rule is like if i had a kid would i
want them seeing this but a lot of girls
don't really follow that rule that's
like the whole thing that happened with
kim kardashian recently when um was it
saint when it was on a random game
online and then just saw an advert for
the her tape
you have an insecurity with that that's
on you i mean that's what girls do like
the shame insult need to be right that's
it's because they do this to me too okay
whenever i like bring up a point with
people on my show and they're wrong they
start to shame you for it
that's what she's doing if you're
insecure just say that the smoke smooth
energy yeah yeah that kind of stuff yeah
whenever it's like whenever someone's
making a point
because because
i think it happens when they have no leg
to stand on that they don't they don't
know what else to say so
and the thing is if it happens the other
way people go crazy if a guy if a guy
will if a guy resorts to that then he's
a every name under the sun so but why is
it okay the other way around
yeah
like what if what if a guy said oh it's
like oh that's whole energy that's yeah
that's small tit energy
you know that's funny
guys we need to we need to make this a
thing no no no don't
stop it
stop it
fire will fire no that's not
you're all about it it's not you're
doing back
two wrongs make right okay
well when you put it like that yeah go
ahead
i'm letting you finish but every time i
let you literally cutting me up right
now like i'm not
[Laughter]
and you're not letting it finish which
one is it jackie this woman is amazing
oh this is funny she's she
thing is i wanna
now i'm lowkey rooting for her because
she's getting annihilated here she's
getting
marin is just is just
finishing her keep keep going jackie
keep it up do this
i believe in you
what are you laughing at no i'm laughing
because you're not let me finish so my
point is this indeed
my point is simply this
men that's how men view relationships
with women they might not admit this but
men are territorial with their women
this is why women that are promiscuous
have a very difficult time getting men
to commit to them because men don't want
to be with women that other men have
been with or they don't want a girl that
has high mileage that's why when you
went to the dealership you paid full
price for that vehicle brought it back
home and then someone said hey i want to
still be able to see it or whatever you
had a point of contention with that why
because you paid full price for the
vehicle and you feel like you're getting
used and abused when you put all the
money down that's how men view
relationships and marriage with women if
i'm going to give you my last name you
cannot go out there and embarrass me men
and women are not the same when it comes
to can i just okay i have a question
so
first off do you ask girls how many
people they've slept with if you're
trying to date them
no i'm not out right no you can't just
tell you can yeah this you can tell
i think the most the most important
thing for me
before before body count is have you
been with anyone that i know that was my
next question that is that's the biggest
thing for me because if if you've so
much has done anything anything with
someone that i know it's done it's
correct it's correct still smash but
but
you're you're out of the race for any
potential relationship
okay this is right
if i
if i if i'm talking to a guy right
but or like just getting to know him
like nothing's happened right i always
make sure i meet the friend group first
because i'm like let me just make sure
there's not
guys if a girl has to meet your friends
say no so you don't have any
just to double check
wait so have you ever like has that ever
happened and you were like
maybe maybe i'm not talking to the right
one have you like
no because i
i'm more of like a friend's first type
of girl like i prefer to so
usually
like there was no expectation that we
were like talking talking maybe maybe i
could hint that maybe he was like
interested
but it wasn't like
that deep yeah yeah no i hate that but
yeah kind of
that's the long way to get around yes
yes i am
um but i always ask guys this question
would you rather
have a girl slept with 20 people you
don't know or one you do know oh 20
people i don't know that's that's what
every guy says
at our wedding i should be the only one
in that room that's seen you naked other
than your parents obviously when you're
a child why don't you invite someone you
slept with your wedding this is the
thing exactly what would you
well if it's someone i know if it's like
my friend then how can he
and he's like a really good friend we
grew up together
how can i be standing
at the altar
my wife is there and then my friend is
there and
he's he's smashed as well
that is that is it's just awkward it'd
be like that yeah
so so no no
it's just just not thinking about it
yeah that's okay it's not real it's not
real it's not real it's okay
it's okay can i now say something please
women sometimes feel the same way we
could be in a relationship with a man
who's gorgeous and he's posting
shirtless tops on instagram and we feel
like oh what men are you dating this is
what i was gonna say the same thing
i don't i don't know
uh like as an adult maybe like when
you're younger as an adult i don't know
one
man who's posting shirtless pics that
isn't
that isn't like
within fitness yeah i don't
i don't either i don't know one like
there's there's no need well that has
happened where i got someone's instagram
at a bar or something and then i saw it
and i'm like oh no
oh no
wait was it at least on the beach
no it was like gym like it was like
a couple years ago i remember this yeah
because i thought he was so cute yeah
and then i saw his instagram and i'm
like nayskey
because it was a whole feed oh it was
just in the bathroom like what
oh that's the worst
man oh
what am i supposed to do with this i was
hoping to see a pic of a dog
no it's actually oh man that's horrible
i know
that's horrible
you know you're that's the thirst trap
right you're wanting attention so why is
it different i don't you just think it's
okay for a guy to do it but not okay for
a girl to do it because you're
territorial we can be territorial too
but it goes
i love this guy
i actually love it
i want to see more of him he is
hilarious
oh i'm scared that is true though like
the girlfriends that are like where are
you going all the time
dude okay do you think though
those girlfriends are territorial or
does the guy just cheat
i mean
i haven't seen the data
just okay out of out of every five
relationships you know like that how
many is the girl crazy or how many does
the guy cheat where's the ball
the girl's not crazy
the girl usually has a reason to
usually has reason to
be that way oh so he's just he'd just be
on the streets like streeting
pretty pretty
got it got it okay i'm just i'm trying
to get in the no i mean oh
at the same time
it okay this is this is really does she
deserve it because she doesn't leave
oh
that's that's a good one
that is a good one
um
because i stayed with the cheater once
and like honestly i feel like i deserved
everything i got i swear to god i said
that
again yeah
and i deserved it
so it's like so i was like like
literally when it happened i'm like you
know
honestly
i should have seen this coming i was
having a conversation with my friend
actually about this
and
this is going to sound wild yeah
i think
maybe some of the guys out there will
will
understand what i'm saying
but sometimes you don't know how much
you love your girlfriend
explain
it's really weird so so oh wait so i got
a question is it like
your your girlfriend throws back right
and then you hook up with another girl
and she throws it back but not as good
and you're like i miss her
it sounds wild when you say it like that
i i'm not saying oh so
should i call him
should i call him
you're doing it because you loved me
i'm doing this for us i want you back
i'm cheating for us
i want you back
call me
oh i'm just kidding please don't please
don't don't do that don't do it that's
terrible relationship advice
at the same time
okay okay okay
okay i i hear you i hear you
about the car is way off because that is
something i've paid for and i own in a
relationship i don't pay for it and i
don't own the person here's the thing
you're you're you're you're letting your
feelings right get in the way of us
she's misunderstanding the point you pay
for it in different ways yeah like your
time actually even as a guy you're
technically financially paying for it as
well uh not paid directly like
indirectly like through and also with
your time and effort so
the payment thing
everything in life is transactional so
the payment thing she's really missing
the point i do i understand what you're
saying about the whole like you don't
own a person but
it's like she's trying not to hear his
point if that makes sense
yeah yeah well i understood what he was
saying because as a guy you're paying
for dates and [ __ ] and you're you're
putting all this time and you gotta
listen to us talk
all right i think that that was the
that was like when my dating life
changed like growing up like
when i realized all you have to do is
just let a woman talk oh my god
everything changed it's like oh so if i
just get you talking i just could i can
just sit here and just just
and you're gonna have a great time
that's true
being advised number two
i'm not i'm thinking rationally
i'm really not
can i please finish my point i'll let
you speak up i'm saying that you say
that that's a really really a past
passive aggressive way great argument
not really because i see what you're
doing i see right through it but go
ahead
i'm here's the thing
i'm explaining to you how men view
relationships you might not like it it
might hurt your feelings you might say
i'm not a piece of property or whatever
but with all due respect [ __ ] your
feelings
you're actually misogynistic and
egotistical and it's it's a kind of a
concern the way you view relationships
like you have ownership of what i want
to say
any guy that wants to pay my bills
[Laughter]
jackie quiet
quiet jackie jackie does not speak for
the rest of the female population
misogynists only
that is why no
none of this equal
partnership oh man look um it's wild
though because like as soon as soon as
she got annoyed
she just threw out the
misogyny word like just it's just it
always happens when
it's it's like the next stage of what
we're talking about before of like like
deflected um
what was it like talking like same shame
yeah oh my god shame then insults
glitch yeah that need to be right is
third textbook let's see what happens
yeah let's let's
women yeah that's kind of how it's
coming across
when do we say we own women yeah when
did we say that it's like you if i'm
gonna give you my last name and i'm
gonna commit to you then you're not
allowed to have a for sale sign around
your neck by being in a bikini that that
kind of behavior is like that scares me
in a relationship well i would never
want to be with the guy none of you
[ __ ] insecure
like i just feel like i see these girls
on social media they'll be posting their
whole body
i'm like y'all are confident i would not
be confident enough to just like put
that out there yeah yeah yeah you know
what i mean
like why is she fighting so hard for
this like she doesn't even what's
jackie's instagram look like i wanna see
jackie's
somehow i get the impression she's not
posting this
yeah so who who are you fighting for
jack i don't know
i think jack is confused yeah
i think she just wants to argue yes she
does
the guy that is like that
a woman can do whatever she wants she
could do whatever she wants
our standards are this if you want to
comply you can you can if you don't want
to you don't have to and remember we're
talking about a committed relationship
with a man so if you put pictures like
that on the internet that's fine you can
do it we never said you can't do it
you're putting words in our mouth i'm
simply saying if i'm gonna commit to you
give you marriage give you a title give
you a ring give you children i expect a
certain type of woman why is it that
when men have standards
exactly i love it how it's just giving
you women no no you're giving it too
much let me finish i should be so
thankful let me finish
look at that need to be right
need to
when a man gives cause here's the thing
women control sex men control
relationships so since i'm the
gatekeeper to relationships you want to
take my last name last time i checked
girls want to walk down an aisle in a
white dress with their daughter with
their father leading them correct to a
man women are the ones that want
security in the marriage so if i'm a man
and i'm going to give you that i need to
vet you and make sure that you are a
good candidate to be my wife oh my god i
want to vomit listening to what you're
saying
first of all you are do you live in the
1960s women are making their own money
these days my friend i am the one that
supports the man in a relationship i
don't need security from a man okay that
might be you
but mostly
my partner is totally secure with that
you guys are full of [ __ ] he hates you
you're a bit of a thirsty [ __ ] though
right when you're doing who do you want
attention
i love him
he is he's the mvp of this video he is
the mv who is this man you need to find
this man's at immediately
no oh my god
i can i can safely say the girl who just
jumped in her husband's not okay with it
he's probably he's probably he's putting
up with it he's not okay with it no he's
definitely okay i've been like
i've been in the situation
where
like early on in my life i was like oh
yeah i'm yeah this is cool
and then it just eats away at you and
then you're like like bro stop like
don't i'm not i'm not here i'm not here
for this so you have to just leave
because yeah like they'll they'll say a
lot of guys will say
what they think is right or politically
correct because they don't want to be
labeled all these buzzwords
and then
but the reality is like yeah you don't
want like every
everyone just being like yeah no man
no
yeah you know what's funny
i
i don't think this should be that big of
a conversation
like i don't understand why this is even
a debate
like don't post your ass on the internet
then she's like well what about the
shirtless selfies like that's a big
problem on instagram
uh
like oh
i see asses all over i don't see
shirtless selfies everywhere
yep there's that's just
yeah
ah is that who you follow up no
i i just have i just have
sports right sportscenter that's it yeah
that's
[Laughter]
we're still gonna get proposed to
[ __ ]
i guarantee you there's no need
i'm just i'm literally like i just think
your views are really antiquated here's
the thing again why is it okay
for because okay
i can't believe i'm defending them but
like any he's my own's right like
whenever a guy
has any form of expectation
women can't handle it no oh my god they
do this to me on my show because i'll
tell them i'm like don't date single
moms leave the whales don't deal with
them what would you put up with that
and the women freak out i had a girl i
had a friend of 20 years
that said she'd stop being friends with
me because i swear to god because i said
that if a guy if a woman gains 50 to 100
pounds in a marriage like that's
disrespectful to your husband and he has
a right to ask you to lose the weight or
leave oh 100 yeah and she was like well
i gained all this weight i'm like i
didn't know that if the shoe fits that's
not my fault
like
maybe you should try losing it like
what's your other option
that's very true
like because you represent your husband
so if i was with like if i was with a
guy i wouldn't want to be in like
embarrass him while his friends are
making fun of him because he's with the
fatty
like i don't you do you want that to be
you and then what do you want yeah so
like but it's funny because whenever men
have any sort of standards or even women
advocating for men having standards they
still freak out why i just i don't get
it it's like we have to accept
everything but then when the shoes on
the other foot me personally i don't
have the issue but like
when i hate when i hear people like oh
yeah um
there's the height there's the money
there's the
there's a bunch of things i'm like okay
so
you have all these criteria
totally fine
what about just just don't be fat
like the whole world goes crazy and you
should be picky with dating
you should you should like do you want
everyone just sleeping with everyone no
the point is being selected
and guys aren't even that selective they
just say no fatties
exactly
and that's in your control
you can you can control that and i i bet
overweight you could lose it it's okay
but a lot of people don't want to do the
work a lot of people get comfortable and
i think especially nowadays it's like
trendy to be a victim oh my god
it's everyone wants to be part of a
group that's getting oppressed or like
is getting i'm just like why do you want
to
like why do you want like surely you
want to do everything in your power to
not experience that but now it's like
it's just a thing that everyone wants
i call it the oppression olympics
everyone's trying to outdo each other
well i'm going through this and i'm
going to shut up man
oh my god
i have a story i'm going to tell you
ladies
no it's true though like i always say i
think that being a woman is an advantage
in the workforce especially a young
woman
you're at an advantage because men help
you
i think men are more likely to help
women they're attracted to to be honest
so like when i worked in sales like all
the guys would complain because i would
go to management for help that i'd get a
meeting that day but they would have to
wait a week
where are the marches for that i'm not
gonna lead him i'm not gonna lead him
sorry troy sorry
sorry i i know it was because i was a
girl
does he watch the show what no
like i said
this is how men view relationships this
is how men generally kill men when
they're unrelated
when you're gay brooklyn what do you use
[Music]
we need to get this guy on the podcast
fly him to miami immediately this guy is
sick
it's like a huge fight here like you
guys i don't think we're never allowed
to talk in this interview it feels
like
here's the thing
you guys asked us to come on your show
we're answering the questions and you
guys are not letting us answer the
questions you're just cutting us off and
changing us or whatever i've definitely
been
make up your mind jackie
have you let him talk or you have it
simply telling you how men feel about
giving their commitment away to women
you don't like the answer but i'm
telling you how men generally think it's
just that they can't say this because
look at how you guys responded to what i
told you shame
guilt insults trying to attack our
masculinity whatever it may be men can't
be honest with women because you guys
can't accept the truth
but it's your opinion
you're saying you're saying you don't
like care like oh i could provide my own
money my own security congratulations
that's great but regardless when women
make a certain amount of money they
still want a man that makes more money
than they do typically around 26 percent
more or no 52 percent more so you can
save those stats from
here in the united states
they want at least 26 or 52
more income than they do women day up
this has been known as the beginning of
time women do not only date their equals
if not preferably higher so if a man is
expected to come in right bring security
make more money etc why can't he have
requirements why is it that a woman can
say i want a guy that makes this much
money this tall this good looking this
charming this confident and a man says
something simple like i don't like to
date women that put sexy photos
themselves on the internet for other men
to see when she's supposed to be my
woman why is that melt with such
contempt from women tell me that
i feel like
that's a mic drop
i i have nothing to say tonight yeah
he's absolutely ripping into them so
what it what'd you think of the video
yeah i just
the guy the
the guy who's on the cam he was he was
making me laugh he was hilarious but
towards the end i was like okay now he's
just trolling now he's now just trolling
everyone but
yeah she had she had no leg to stand on
she
she didn't she asked the questions and
because she didn't like the answers
she refused to even
try to understand what was being said
instead
like she was arguing for the sake of
argument and she was listening to
respond not to
take it in
men don't respond like that
like i because i debate with women and
men all the time
like i only see girls do that isn't that
weird do the whole like shaming yeah
yeah because we we we can't we there's
there is okay because if we do it to
another guy it's gonna
it's gonna escalate yeah so we know that
we have to find a way to get to and we
can't do it to women yeah so like we
it's like you're trained throughout your
whole life in order to handle the
situations in in in a different way
because if we if we're if we if i'm with
another guy and we start talking and
then
he calls me a [ __ ] instantly okay
it's now escalated to shout in and then
if you wanna you know i mean so we we
there's always an element of danger and
escalation so we know not to do that if
that makes sense okay this is why i want
to start a movement called hit the
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
no i swear to god
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay hold on hold on explain explain i
need to i need to hear more about this
because this is okay okay hear me out
hear me out okay so
i think if a girl brings a knife to the
fight and is punching you you should be
able to hit back and knock the [ __ ] out
yeah there i think that man in miami
would be alive if he just hit a [ __ ]
and everyone's saying oh never hit women
never hit women i used to think like
that and then i started to see the kind
of punches these women were throwing oh
oh yeah yeah because i'm sorry if a
skinny dude like if a five-five guy
walks up to you
and punches you even if it's a wimpy ass
punch you punch him back knock him out
nobody would say [ __ ] because he started
it
i'm just saying hit the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
girls were a little scared of getting
hit i think our behavior would be a
little bit better i do
i do
oh we need to we need to
come back on the podcast and we need to
talk about this movement you want to
start because this is hilarious look
i am so dead oh lord okay
well that's my final thought hit the
[ __ ]
if your girl has an instagram
if it's okay i think if a girl has a
private instagram and it's like a got
200 300 followers it's no big deal yeah
yeah my opinion but i agree with him the
ass
on the internet just too much too much
yeah it's just
what are your closing thoughts are you
team hit the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
cancel them do it do it
i
i am i am not team hit the [ __ ]
i just just help
no no i'm not i'm not
however i will
i'll come to the matches and show my
support for your movement
it's all i've ever won
[Laughter]
yeah yeah i thought about this
too much
oh but yeah um again just in general
sorry yeah just in general
um myron did really well he did so well
he did really well on that fresh was
useless as always
[Laughter]
he's just there for vibes
um and then yeah the woman was just
irritating i don't i don't want to smash
her past
i mean off the voice
[Laughter]
just like from bar
[Laughter]
oh
no yeah she's yeah
you know what the one that the one that
jumped in and said oh i'm engaged at
that one yeah smash yeah yeah okay okay
what are any other closing thoughts um
yeah just make sure guys if you if you
truly love your girl um be sure to just
really find out how much you love her
by cheating on her
um
please um no guy that dates me in the
future listen to this
please don't
i might stay though i might
i'm just kidding
i'm just kidding
okay guys um you really should check out
um
his podcast it's honestly it's so funny
i was there the other day
and oh my god i watched a show before
our show and i was dying laughing like
it was so funny
um the links to that will be in the
description um so you have a youtube
channel or is it your podcast yeah so
yeah we we're on youtube um yeah just
check us out on there um
on all audio platforms as well
spotify amazon music apple podcast uh
it's called shambles fm
so yeah just check us out okay guys
don't forget to subscribe okay if you've
watched two or more of my videos you
don't just subscribe we got beef okay
yeah beef
okay bye guys i'll talk to you next time